But first,
I want to introduce you to another idea,
it's the idea of one
by one convolutions.
You might wonder, why might one ever
want to use one by one convolutions?
They're not really looking at a patch
of the image, just that one pixel.
Look at the classic convolution setting.
It's basically a small classifier for
a patch of the image, but
it's only a linear classifier.
But if you add a one by one convolution
in the middle, suddenly you have
a mini neural network running over the
patch instead of a linear classifier.
Interspersing your convolutions
with one by one convolutions
is a very inexpensive way to
make your models deeper and
have more parameters without
completely changing their structure.
They're also very cheap,
because if you go through the math,
they're not really convolutions at all.
They're really just matrix multiplies,
and they have relatively few parameters.
I mention all of this, average pooling
and one by one convolutions because I
want to talk about a general strategy
that has been very successful at
creating covnets that
are both smaller and
better than covnets that simply
use a pyramid of convolutions.